Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich bin der Diensthafen der Arzt heute.
Ich kümmere mich um Sie.
Wie heißen Sie?
Fatma Nurgul.
Können Sie bitte für mich Ihre Vor- und Nachname bestabieren?
Fatma mit F-A-T-M-A.
Und Nurgul mit N-U-R-G-U-L.
Nurgul, ich spiele Ihre Namen richtig aus?
Ja, genau.
Bevor wir über Ihre Beschwerden spieren,
würde ich gerne ein paar allgemeine Fragen über Sie stimmen.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 40 Jahre alt.
Wie bitte?
40 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau?
Ich habe einen Tag und ein Monat.
Das ist der 1. Juni 1982.
1.
1. Juni 1982.
Wie groß sind Sie?
71.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
80.
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Warum ich hier gekommen bin?
Ich habe eine Schwellung im Hals.
Seit heute oder gestern ist das das 1.
Seit ungefähr 3-4 Wochen.
Aber ich habe es auch nicht so ernst genommen.
Die Familie umkreuzt, die haben mir gesagt,
ich muss mich jetzt beim Arzt vorstellen,
und deswegen bin ich hier gekommen.
Dann habe ich mich richtig verstanden,
Frau Nurgul.
Sie haben beidseitig im Hals Schwellungen seit 3-4 Wochen.
Es ist länger, seit 3-4 Wochen zu nehmen.
Seit 3-4 Wochen?
Nehmen Sie sich doch.
Die vergrossen sich langsam.
Sind Sie in meinen Schwellungen schmerzhaft oder ohne Schmerzen?
Ich spüre fast keine Schmerzen.
Mit der Untersuchung sehe ich auch selbst.
Aber würde ich gerne fragen,
in Ihrem anderen körperlichen Bereich,
in dem Sie sich in den Schwellen haben,
wie Sie sich in den Schwellen haben,
wie Sie sich in den Axie- oder Marmalbereich bemerken?
Ich habe es nicht kontrolliert, selbst so zu sagen.
Ich habe es nicht gefühlt, so zu sagen.
Aber Sie können gerne unterhalten.
Aber Sie können gerne untersuchen.
Sie haben gesagt, seit 3-4 Wochen vergrößert sich.
Hatten Sie eine Infektion oder etwas besonderes Fieber?
Ich habe ungefähr vor 6 Wochen
Schmerzen gehabt mit einer Entzündung.
Am Ende musste ich ein Antibiotisch anbehandeln.
Das habe ich auch gemacht, so zu sagen.
Ich habe es auch angenommen.
Ich war beim Arzt, der hat es auch nicht angeschaut.
Ob ich damals dieser Vergrößerung hatte oder nicht.
Ich nehme das an, das ist auch ein bisschen nach dieses Prozess,
das ich damals hatte, alles aufgetreten sind.
Welche Antibiotik haben Sie damals angenommen?
Ich kann es nicht genau erzählen.
Da hat Maas verschrieben, also eine Woche, 10 Tage.
Über Ihre Schwelmungen, sind Sie beweglich oder stehen Sie fest?
Das kann ich nicht unterscheiden.
Wenn Sie Ihre Schwelmungen anfassen,
wie fühlen Sie sich?
Es ist ganz genau rund, die Grenzen sind bestimmt oder unbestimmte Grenzen?
Haben die Schwelmungen?
Sie fragen so etwas fachlich.
Ich habe es nicht angeschaut und angefasst, zu sagen.
Ich habe es nie gespürt.
Es ist ganz okay.
Ich werde auf jeden Fall Ihnen körperlich selbst untersuchen.
Aber erst mal muss ich auch diese Frage stellen.
Bitte, ich höre Sie.
Ich werde Sie weiterregnen.
Über die Schwelmungen habe ich gerade keine Fragen,
aber muss ich ein paar andere Fragen stellen.
Sie haben schon gesagt, vor sechs Wochen hatten Sie Halsmessen
und deswegen haben Sie damals antibiotische Therapie angenommen.
Sie haben nach der antibiotischen Therapie
nachschweißt?
Ich habe es damals gehabt.
Nachschweißt nicht.
Als Sie gesagt haben,
ich habe beim Arzt versucht,
und dann antibiotische Therapie verschrieben.
Da habe ich es auch genommen.
Ich habe es dann gemacht.
Nach der Behandlung mit der Antibiotik
nachdem diese Beschwerde nach Halsmessen beendet wurde,
bis dahin, bis hier, haben Sie viel wahr
mit unbestimmter Grunde.
Ich höre richtig leise.
Ich meine,
als ich diese Enzinnung hatte,
bis jetzt, habe ich noch Fieberhaar.
Das habe ich nicht.
Das war nur kurzfristig.
Die Beutelung nach drei, vier Tagen war auch weg.
Sie sind auch noch nicht mitgekommen.
Sie sind abgenommen oder zugenommen?
Ich meine, in den letzten sechs Monaten?
Ich habe es abgenommen oder zugenommen.
Ihr habt es nicht darauf geachtet.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich es stark abgenommen habe.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit voran?
In der letzten Zeit auch nicht ganz okay, muss ich sagen.
Ich bin so schnell satt,
nach drei, vier Lüffeln bin ich satt.
Wie ist Ihre Slafe?
Auch nicht ganz gut.
Ich mache mir jetzt Gedanken.
Auch dadurch ist es ein Schlafstuhl.
Ab und zu stehe ich auf in der Nacht.
Aber insgesamt ist es nicht so schlecht.
Das geht.
Aber Sie haben Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein, habe ich auch keine Probleme.
Alles klar.
Ich würde gerne über Ihre Vorgeschichte spüren.
Leiden Sie unter eine chronische Krankheit.
Hochblutdruck oder Suckerkrankheit zum Beispiel?
Ob ich unter einem Blutdruck Krankheit leiden
oder Suckerkrankheit?
Nein, ich war kein gesund.
Ich habe nie Medikamente eingenommen, ab und zu schon.
Bei Bedarf, aber ich kenne mich nicht mit Erkrankungen.
Nehmen Sie mal die Medikamente ein,
aber bei Bedarf nehmen Sie manchmal die Medikamente.
Ja, während der Regel, wenn man Schmeißen hat,
nehmen wir das ein, aber sonst nehmen wir es gar nicht.
Was nehmen Sie dafür?
Ein Parasitambol.
In Ihrem Vorgeschichte ist Ihnen die Opis oder Unfälle bekannt?
Was Sie haben es nicht genau verstanden?
Ein Griech zum Beispiel, Bilddarmentwärmung oder Mangelentwärmung.
Sie haben eine OP, meine ich habe keine OP.
Wie ist Ihre Impfstatus?
Sind Sie durchgeimpft gegen die Corona?
Ja, sogar geburstert auch.
Waren Sie zwischendurch im Ausland?
Nein.
Fahren Sie fahren oder?
Ab und zu.
Seit wann?
Seit ungefähr zehn Jahren, aber ich rauche nur so ein, zwei pro Tag, nicht so viel.
Können Sie Alkohol?
Nein.
Nehmen Sie bitte diese Frage nicht unangenehm, aber ich muss diese Frage für meine alle Patientinnen und Patientinnen erzählen.
Ist Ihnen mit den Drogen eine Kontaktbekannt in Ihrem Leben?
Nein, habe ich nie Drogen genommen.
Es ist mir so viel.
Wir sind fast am Ende, aber Kostafo muss sich ein paar Fragen über Ihre sexuelle Leben stellen.
Sind Sie noch immer sexuell aktiv?
Ja.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Geschlechtsverkehr?
Nein, ich habe keine Probleme.
Haben Sie noch immer Ihre Regelbelückung?
Ja.
Ist das regelmäßig?
Das ist auch regelmäßig.
Schmeißen ist normal.
Das ist heute drei Tage, aber danach nicht mehr.
Okay.
Über Ihre Familie, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja.
Sind Sie gesund oder leiden Sie unter einen?
Ja, wir sind gesund. Wir sind auch gar nicht gesund.
Haben Sie das auch?
Ich habe einen Bruder, der ist ungefähr 30 Jahre alt, der ist auch gar nicht gesund.
Alles klar.
Meine letzte Frage ist, ist Ihnen die bestimmte Medikamente oder Lebensmittel allergienbekannt?
Nein, er ist auch nicht bekannt.
Ich bin gerade durch mit meinen Fragen.
Haben Sie Fragen für mich oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich habe keine Fragen.
Ich möchte wissen, was ich habe.
Wie können Sie mich damit helfen, damit ich aus dieser Stress rauskommen kann?
Das ist nachvollziehbar.
Ich kann das total verstehen.
Ich werde erst mal Ihnen körperlich untersuchen und diese Schwelchungen selbst sehen.
Danach muss ich Blut abnehmen.
Danach sehen wir mit den Ultraschalen und gucken die Quadresteck unter die Haut.
Ist es auch möglich, dass wir eine Nymphprobe,
eine Schwelbeprobe von Ihren Schwelchungen entfernen können.
Aber bis dahin haben wir noch immer Zeit.
Wie ich gesagt habe, erst mal muss ich mit den körperlichen Untersuchungen
und die Laborwerte weitergehen.
Danach kann ich Ihnen bessere und klarer Antwort geben.
Okay, gerne.
Dann bin ich, das heißt, ich werde aufgenommen und bleibe ins Krankenhaus.
Erst mal, ja.
Ich möchte noch zur Sicherheit wieder fragen stellen.
Fühlen Sie sich, auch wenn das Wetter kalt ist?
Noch mal Wetter, ich habe die Frage nicht gehört.
Nicht ganz, aber in der Nacht habe ich so natürlich
Schweißausprobe seit ungefähr einer Woche.
Aber so ein ganz warm finde ich mich nicht.
Haben Sie Schluckbeschwerden oder ein Kloskgefühl im Heiß?
Wir auch nicht.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit bemerkt, dass Sie Nervositat,
Unriehe, Müdigkeit, Konzentration schwer oder haben?
Konzentration, so eine Störung, meinen Sie,
ob ich deine Nänze Zeit habe?
Natürlich, bisschen schon.
Durch die Schwellungen mache ich mich Gedanken und daraufhin
bin ich so ein natürliches Mensch und wir reagieren halt darauf
und habe ich dadurch ein bisschen Konzentration für die Störung.
Okay, danke schön.
Sie haben gesagt, keine Stülverhalten ist,
aber leiden Sie irgendwelche unter Durchfall?
Durchfall habe ich auch nicht, nein, auch wieder Verstoffung.
Ich habe kein Problem mit der Mischung.
Ich würde auch gefragt, ich gehe davon aus.
Sind Ihnen Blässe oder Zittern aufgefallen?
Noch mal bitte, was mir aufgefallen?
Sind Ihnen Ihre Haut oder Konzentration,
Blässe, Farbänderung?
Ob ich eine Farbänderung in meiner Haut gemerkt habe oder gesehen habe,
nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Alles, das war's, danke schön.
Wie viel Kilogramm abgenommen?
Ich habe nicht gehört, ich denke, wie viel Kilogramm abgenommen?
Wie viel Kilogramm?
Ich glaube, das ist gefragt worden, ob ich Kilogramm abgenommen habe.
Ich habe gesagt, keine große Änderung eigentlich, oder?
War das meine Antwort?
Ja.
Danke schön.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
Das habe ich auch beantwortet.
In der letzten Woche, ja.
Aber das ist Juckreis?
Juckreis, nein, habe ich nicht.
Hab das ein Brustschmerzen?
Brustschmerzen, nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Okay.
Und Kopfschmerzen?
Ja, das sind, hat normal.
Es ist nicht, dass ich sage, dass ich jetzt wegen Kopfschmerzen
ins Krankenhaus geben muss oder zum Arzt gehen muss.
Vielleicht schon.
Als ob noch?
Auch nicht.
Okay, danke.
Danke.
Okay, ich glaube, habe meine Antwort.
Haben wir alles gefragt?
Nein, nee, warte auf.
So, meine Oberarzt, ich habe heute eine neue Patiente
von der unsere Notaufnahme aufgenommen,
aber wenn Sie kurz Zeit für mich,
das wir darüber diskutieren können.
Sie haben gerade in der Notaufnahme gesehen
und Sie haben sie aufgenommen, oder?
Ja, genau.
Okay, gerne.
Fortmanögen, 40-jährige Patientin,
die übergewichtigt ist.
Sie lagte über seit 3-4 Wochen
für verschlechterte Schwellungen im Halsbereich
breitzeitig.
Sie berichtet, dass sie keine andere...
Zunehmende Schwellungen, nicht verschlechterte.
Okay, zunehmende.
Zunehmende Schlechterung, das kann man nicht benutzen.
Entweder eine Vergrößerte.
Oder eine Vergrößerte der Lämpfknoten
oder eine Vergrößerte der unklare Digenität,
kann man auch sagen, aber auch wahrscheinlich das Lämpfknoten.
Ich muss ihn auch unterbrechen.
Ich muss immer korrigieren.
So war das gewünscht.
Ja, kein Problem.
Ich habe gesagt, dass unsere Patientin
über seit 3-4 Wochen zunehmende Schwellungen im Halsbereich
breitzeitig lag.
Die Schmerzen wurden von den Patientinnen verneint.
Diese Schwellung ist untoll.
Ja, untoll.
Sie hat in einem anderen Bereich von der Körper
keine andere oder weitere Schwellungen bemerkt.
Meine Frage wäre, ob wir eine Auslösung finden können.
Ich habe gesagt, dass sie vor 6 Wochen
wegen der Halsmerzen mit der Antibiotikum behandelt wurde.
Abgesehen davon kann sie leider nicht über die Beweglichkeit
oder Grenze von den Schwellungen uns etwas berichten.
B-Symptome wurde von ihr verneint.
Sie hat auch wie gesagt, dass ihr gerade mit...
Eigentlich so Schweißausbruch seit einer Woche hat sie...
Das habe ich nicht gehört.
... erwähnt.
Weil haben wir unsere Reden, kann sein, aber Schweißausbruch, ja.
Schweißausbruch.
Bis auf Schweißausbruch ohne B-Symptomatik, bis auf Schweißausbruch.
Das heißt, der hat nur eine von den B-Symptomen.
Genau.
Aber so, sie hat kein Fieber.
Zwischendurch ist sie nicht abgenommen.
Und die vegetative Anamnese, unauffällig und vorgeschichte
mit den chronischen Erkrankungen, ist unauffällig.
Sie ist durchgeimpft und gebüstet für die Corona,
gegen die Corona.
Bei ihr ist die Nikotin Abwürzels bekannt.
Sie ruft ab und zu.
Im Goshinganzen können wir sagen, ein Paket, ja.
Kein Alkohol, kein Drogen, keine Allergien, ist eher bekannt.
Und Familienanamnese ist unauffällig.
Und keine Schluckwärter, keine Müdigkeit,
keine andere Zentrum.
Okay.
Was haben Sie beim Köpferuntersuchung erfasst oder gesehen?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Wir fragen so an, etopisch, ja.
Okay.
Was würden Sie selbst machen, dann fragen wir so alles.
In diesem Fall.
In diesem Fall, so ich würde weiter mit den Schwierigungen gehen.
In diesem Fall haben die Beweglichkeit und die Grenze
von den Schwierigungen große Wichtigkeit.
Seit drei bis vier Wochen.
Das heißt, Sie werden die Schwierigungen genau anschauen
und untersuchen.
Das heißt, Sie werden die Art von der Schwierigung genau anschauen.
Die Lokalisation auch in den Grenzen.
Das ist Ihre Aussage, was Sie sagen wollten, oder?
Ja, genau.
Was würden Sie denn achten mit so was, wenn Sie in seiner Schwierigung haben?
Was würden Sie denn genau anschauen?
Ob die Schwierigungen beweglich sind oder sind sie fest sind.
Und mit der Grenze würde ich gerne gucken, ob Sie bestimmte Grenze haben.
Kann man mittels eine Instinktion, eine Grenze erfassen
oder dafür brauchen Sie eine Olderschein?
Wie bitte?
Kann man mittels eine Instinktion, Sie müssen inspexieren.
Sie müssen genau mit dem Hand einfach untersuchen.
Ist es möglich, dass man die Grenze von der Lymphknoten
mit Hand einfach zu erfassen oder zu bestimmen,
ob die regelmäßig sind oder um regelmäßig sind.
Aber überhaupt eine Rolle spielt auch.
Das verstehe ich so.
Eigentlich ist es gut darauf, welche körperliche Regionen
wir untersuchen, aber im Halsbereich und insbesondere in die Gesicht.
Die Lymphknoten oder die Schwierigungen liegt ganz unter der Haut.
In diesem Fall kann ich mir gut vorstellen,
dass ich das bemerken kann.
Sie werden natürlich die Vergrößerung der Art von Schwierigungen erfassen.
Aber die Grenze wird schwierig.
Sie brauchen eine Olderschein, und das ist auch nicht wichtig bei Lymphknoten.
Man muss nicht unbedingt, aber sie brauchen eine Olderschein.
Was würden Sie noch achten, wenn Sie so etwas haben?
Ob sie doolent oder indolent sind.
Die Patientin hat schon darüber berichtet, dass sie undolent sind.
Aber vielleicht hat sie nie mit den Anpassungen oder mit den Passen.
Genau, das ist sehr wichtig.
Schmeckt ein schmerzhaftes Lymphknoten,
sondern wenn man tastet.
Was würden Sie noch achten, wenn Sie so etwas sehen?
Wie Sie aussehen, ist schon das Wächter.
Ob Sie Rütteln haben oder eine bestimmte Wunde.
Oder zum Beispiel eine Wunde von einem Tier.
Das kann auch sein.
Man hat Kontakt mit einer Richtung der Ursache, wo Sie kommen können.
Sie wollen den Umfeld Diagnostik nachfragen.
Ob die Patientin zu Hause Katze hat.
Auslandreise haben Sie auch gefragt.
Drohungen haben Sie auch gefragt,
wegen der HIV oder anderen Infektionsübertragungen.
Die haben nicht außer den Haustier gefragt.
Das könnte Sie nachfragen.
Wie gehen Sie dann um weiter?
Nach der Untersuchung würde ich Blutabnehmen und gucken,
ob die Infektionsparameter erhöht sind.
Ob wir andere Gründe finden können.
Bei einer Mleser sind wir fertig.
Haben wir alles gefragt?
Oder gibt es noch Fragen?
Ich habe nichts eingeproht.
Sie haben alles gefragt.
Manchmal auch chronische Kranken.
Sie haben in der Mleser nachgefragt,
ob die chronische Kranken oder Tumor hatten.
Sie haben nicht alles gefragt.
Sie können den Körperuntersuch durchgeführt.
Was machen wir weiter?
Nach der Untersuchung würde ich Blutabnehmen und Labo-Werte gucken.
Dann würde ich diese Schwelmung untersuchen.
Ich werde mit der Gewerbe probieren.
Ich werde mit der Nadel-Biopsy weitergehen.
Sie machen einen sehr schnellen Arzt.
Sie versuchen, die Richtigkeit der Pathologie zu bringen.
Aber bevor wir das machen,
was würden Sie noch machen?
Können Sie auf die Entscheidung kommen,
dass Sie eine Biopsy entnehmen?
Ob die andere körperliche Teil
auch die Schwelmungen hat,
würde ich das gucken.
Ich werde mit einer Hals-Lymph-Knoten
nachgehen und anschauen.
Dann würde ich eine gesamte Körperuntersuchung
mit einer Pagpastion und einer Bildgebung.
Sie werden auch eine Rücken von Lungen durchführen.
Sie werden auch eine Abdominal-Utasche durchführen.
Sie werden auch erfassen, was sie sehen.
Auch wenn man nichts findet,
mit dieser Art von Untersuchung,
was würden Sie noch machen?
Ich würde gerne mit dem Mamogöffi weitergehen,
weil es eine Quau ist.
Es ist schnell.
Wir sind im Haal,
bevor wir die Kuloren schicken,
welcher Untersuchung brauchen wir?
Ich würde den A&H-mäßig vorstellen.
Das ist A&H-Hals-Nasen-Ornart.
Sie haben Lymphknoten im Haal.
Die erste Frage ist,
ob man die Lymphknoten an den Haalen nicht unbedingt
um Genealogien schicken muss.
Das können Sie machen, das ist nicht verkehrt.
Dann sind Sie mal an den Haalen schicken, ob die was im Haal hat.
Die Lymphknoten hat eine Lymphaldyneopathie verursacht.
Das ist ungewöhnlich, warum.
Bei der Tarrade der Lymphknoten sieht man
auch bei genealogischer Tumoren,
wenn Sie auch nicht bei Zerlymphknoten sehen.
Er ist ein einseitig.
Aber eine Lymphomartik-Krankung sieht so aus.
Dann sehen Sie am meisten so ein beienseitig.
Manchmal einseitig, aber er ist ein weise.
Sehr gut.
Weil sie eine Frau ist,
wenn sie auch genealogisch vorstellt,
das müssen Sie auch selbst machen.
Wenn Sie eine Knoten erfassen,
dann müssen Sie eine Genealogin schicken.
Das kann man auch fragen, ob Sie auf das Genealogin gehen,
eine Vorsorgeuntersuchung, was uns zuletzt gewesen war.
Wie gehen Sie weiter jetzt?
Wir haben jetzt gesagt,
was wir jetzt sagen mussten,
was wir gehen Sie weiter jetzt?
Wenn die Laborwerte normal sind,
dann sind sie normal.
Sie haben gar nichts gesehen im Laborwerte.
Ultraschall ist auch normal.
Ultraschall, Sie haben eine Lymphknoten
in der Lebewahr vorgestellt,
aber an sich bis dahin war unaufwendig.
Röntgen ist auch unaufwendig.
Und die Untersuchung bei Dich war ganz normal.
Das war es bei dem Hals?
Ja, der hat keinen Schmelzen.
Eine ganz normale Lymphknotenvergrößerung,
und klarer Steginität,
hat Schweißausbruch, richtig.
Wie gehen Sie weiter?
Im Runde, wenn man fragt,
kann jeder auch beantworten.
Wenn jemand ein Idiot hat,
kann er auch beantworten.
Wir machen so ein Relagen zusammen.
Es geht nicht um Sprache zu verbessern,
sondern auch so eine Basis,
Informationen zu refreschen.
Das ist auch wichtig.
Ich würde in diesem Fall,
wenn ich eine junge Patientin habe,
dann würde ich bei Unklarheit
eine CT durchspülen.
Wenn Sie eine Lymphknotenvergrößerung haben,
dann ist es unklar,
das Genese, anamnistisch, wie die Infektion,
und auch wenn ein Hohesag,
ich habe nichts außer der Lymphknoten gesehen,
dann mache ich doch eine CT.
Was für CT braucht man hier?
Nein, für Schwangerschaft
und für uns ist es keine CT.
Ich würde vorher gucken, ob Sie...
Ja, das müssen Sie sowieso.
Dann haben Sie das auch gefragt.
Da müssen Sie auch den Verhütung fragen,
wie verhütet sich.
Sie haben in Sexuelles Aktivität gefragt, ob sie aktiv ist,
aber Sie haben nicht gefragt, wie verhütet sie sich.
Medikamentose oder Spirale,
ja, dem Gruppen kommt der Hals und Torax CT,
das finde ich gut, das würde ich auch machen.
Wenn ich den Torax machen würde ich den Abdomen auch machen,
das ist nicht verkehrt, dann habe ich alles im Blick.
Dann mache ich CT Torax als Abdomen,
weil bei Lymphomensalter Standard, was man macht,
da gibt es noch andere, weitere Untersuchungen,
aber erst mal, das reicht das aus.
Das würden Sie machen, warum?
Weil Lymphknoten im Hals,
das gibt doch nichts, das ist nicht mehr so.
Lymphknoten im Hals ist unklar, daher muss man das klären, willkommen.
Und danach, wenn Sie jetzt alles durchgeführt haben,
CT Torax auf dem Hals,
Sie haben jetzt im CT Torax gesehen,
dass die leichterankale Lymphknotenfallgroßerung hat,
auch im Abdomen, ein Sonne-Solidarsteller,
dann, was würden Sie machen als Nächstes?
Genau.
Ich fühle mich, dass ich es mal mit der Biopsy anbringe, aber...
Ja, genau, Sie wollen auf diesem Bereich kommen,
direkt zu Biopsyren,
wie biopsiert man seine Lymphknoten?
Nadelbiopsy, oder...
...ganze Lymphknoten in Seine...
Genau, das heißt, komplett entnehmen des Lymphknoten,
das ist besser, das Beste, das ist was man machen.
Weil, wenn Sie mit dem Nadel rein gehen,
Sie werden manchmal keine auffällige Zellen treffen,
sondern auch nur für Lichtflüssigkeit.
Und daher, man versucht es,
dann Extreparation, sagt man das,
Extreparation, das heißt, Sie werden den den ganzen Lymphknoten
mit der Capsal zusammen rausnehmen
und einfach in die Pathologie schicken.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und sonst dann, ich glaube,
soweit haben wir alles besprochen.
Biopsier haben wir besprochen, Diagnostik,
ich würde jetzt nicht umgehen,
welche Art von Tumor, so eine Häuschklinge im Fohren
oder eine Anhäuschklinge im Fohren,
das brauchen wir nicht so zu wissen,
weil das wird nicht gefragt in der Profekt.
Vor euch was zu wissen ist,
wie man umgeht mit so einer Unklarheit mit Lymphknoten.
Sie haben toll gemacht, anonystisch,
Sie haben erstmal seinen Körper untersucht,
was man achten muss,
was man umgeht mit so einer unklarer Lymphknoten,
dass man die Grunderkrankungen,
ob die eine Kroneerkrankung oder Tumerkrankungen hat im Leben,
ob das eine Residiv von der Art der Erkrankung ist,
oder Medikamentose, Medikamenteinnahme,
Geschichte, ob das eine Medikamenteintersitzung,
die eine Partie ist.
Reise haben Sie gefragt,
im Staatsamt haben Sie gefragt,
Sex-Saleaktivitäten, das kann man vertiefen,
das hat auch nicht das Wichtigste zu wissen,
weil das je mehr, das schlechter geht,
zum den Naturschicht und den Sexualinfektion übertragen.
Das kann man auch fragen,
aber Sie haben es nicht vertieft,
aber das ist was man machen können.
Drohrenamese haben Sie gemacht
und Kontakt mit Tieren,
Auslernreise haben Sie auch gefragt.
Sie haben es toll gemacht, muss ich sagen.
Mehr bleibt nichts übrig, was man freieren soll,
in so einer Fall.
Was mir gut gefahren ist,
richtig muss man sagen,
ob die Stimpfkulonen schmerzhaft sind oder nicht.
Das ist sehr wichtig, das zu unterscheiden.
Wenn die sind sichtbare, vergrößer,
und impfkulonen schmerzhaft sind,
die wachsen schnell,
dann ist es eine Infektion,
da braucht man keine Cp,
wir sparen von so was,
da muss man gar nichts machen.
Wo warten wir das nehmen,
gehen wir an die Bütiker und wo warten wir das?
Manchmal muss man 6-7 Monate beobachten.
Aber wenn das von Anfang an
schmerzt, wo es lebt,
wenn man die Auftrittszeit und die Beidzeit,
das ist dann auffällig,
dann muss man schon was machen.
Sie haben es toll gemacht, muss ich sagen.
Ich glaube, wenn man pruchen soll,
wenn jemand sich durchfahre,
dann haben sie bestimmt Feind gegen sie.
Auf, soll ich nicht.